huge changes never before seen
characters Mythic skins hero missions
and a new free-to-play model here's
everything you need to know about
OverWatch 2.
blizzard is overhauling overwatch's
current Pace structure with the upcoming
sequel making the core multiplayer game
free to play and eliminating loot boxes
instead there will now be an in-game
store additional PVE content available
to purchase and battle passes that offer
in-game cosmetics and other fun perks
but what about OverWatch 1 well once
OverWatch 2 launches OverWatch 1 will no
longer exist as the game is free to play
it is essentially rolling out as an
update this ensures all OverWatch
players will be able to play with one
another regardless of what your
preferred console is you'll be able to
play with your friends on every system
thanks to OverWatch 2's cross-play
feature
the game will have a seasonal model that
will deliver a unique theme and over 80
tiers of new content to the game every
nine weeks this new content can then be
attained by the player through a battle
pass at the start of each season all
players will get a new free battle pass
as you play the game over the course of
the Season you'll chip away your battle
pass and earn exclusive rewards
including a new Hero at tier 55 every
other season for 1000 OverWatch coins
valued at 10 you can purchase a premium
battle pass this battle PASS gives you
access not only to all the rewards
included with the free battle pass but
instant access to the new hero and some
significantly more elaborate cosmetic
items it also grants you a 15 boost to
your XP gained meaning you'll be
breezing through your tears a bit faster
than you would with the free pass if you
missed a mission or didn't get a chance
to earn its corresponding hero blizzard
has assured players that's all he heroes
from past seasons can be earned through
weekly challenges or directly purchased
in the shop with OverWatch coins
[Music]
OverWatch coins by completing challenges
you can think of these as in-game
achievements or trophies if you
accomplish a certain feat you earn some
points these challenges will range from
things such as win a game to play 10
games as Heroes outside of your three
most played you'll earn coins for
completing a set number of these each
week making it possible to earn enough
throughout a season to earn your premium
battle pass
OverWatch 2 will includes new takes on
the combat we saw in the original game
that includes a brand new game mode
called push in which two teams fight to
escort a robot into enemy territory the
team that pushes the robot furthest into
the other team's territory before time
is up will win the match the most
notable change is that the game will
move to 5v5 matches as opposed to the
current 6v6 model team composition is
also being adjusted so that squads sport
only a one tank character per team over
OverWatch 2 will have all new PVP maps
for push mode but also for every current
core game mode confirmed new maps to
OverWatch 2 include Gothenburg Toronto
Monte Carlo Rio de Janeiro New York Rome
Esperanza
tired of your teammates not staying on
the payload you're in luck as OverWatch
2 is introducing a new and significantly
improved ping system to strengthen
communication between teammates the new
system features more commands than ever
before and allows players to precisely
ping locations alerting their teammates
to enemies and allowing for more
strategic plays
story missions are a new feature in
OverWatch 2 though they won't hit the
game until 2023 they will be heavily
curated PVE missions where players will
only be able to select from a limited
contextually relevant roster of
characters every single Story Mission
will have its own cinematic intro and
outro video hero missions are another
new PVE feature designed to be deeply
replayable thanks to three factors
outlined by blizzard varied locations
which will take players across new maps
and old constantly changing objectives
which will keep the gameplay fresh and
varied and different enemy groups such
as null sector Talon and other threats
certain objectives or enemy types May
demand certain types of heroes to
counter allowing more Hands-On time for
players stuck playing their main in PvP
the newly introduced item system is
exclusive to story missions rather than
a loot system like Diablo OverWatch 2's
item system will work in much the same
way items do in games such as Apex
Legends and pubg according to
overwatch's previous director Jeff
Kaplan temporary item pickups that you
can use for the duration of the mission
these include a corrosive grenade a
healing station or a barrier fence items
also come in tears depending on their
quality
[Music]
OverWatch 2 will introduce a new
progression system designed exclusively
for hero missions it will allow Heroes
to level up and unlock talents that give
them additional perks in combat and is
meant as a strictly PVE non-competitive
mode feature a series of talents for
Tracer were shown off at BlizzCon 2019
but Kaplan warned that the progression
system was still very early in
development and could change a lot the
talent system won't be implemented in
PvP
OverWatch 2 will introduce new playable
Heroes every other season or
approximately every 18 weeks these will
include both characters that are brand
new and characters you've been waiting
for it will also carry over every hero
from the first OverWatch confirmed
Heroes new to OverWatch 2 include sojon
junk Queen and kiriko described as a
mid-range specialist with increased
mobility and artillery skills sojon's
primary weapon is a railgun that
generates energy on each successful hit
and can then consume that power for a
high impact shot this makes sojon well
suited for players with Marksman skills
as they can use that accuracy to deal
devastating blows with the railgun's
secondary fire mode in addition sojon
also has an area of effect ability that
will snare enemies and eat away at the
health a rocket-powered slide and an
ultimate ability called overclock during
overclock sojourn can fire shots that
pierce through enemies secondary fire on
the railgun enables her to quickly
eliminate enemies with high-powered
shots which blizzard likened to a hit
scan version of Genji's dragonblade
attack teased for years by blizzard
Jungle Queen is the not so benevolent
ruler of junkertown equipped with a
mohawk six-pack abs a shotgun and a
battle ax Jungle Queen is The Game's
newest tank and seems more incapable of
leading her team to Victory described as
a Fierce and resourceful survivalist
junk Queen's play kit perfectly
showcases how it will to not only
survive but thrive in the harsh
Australian Outback her passive ability
allows her to heal her wounds over time
by dealing damage to other players
encouraging those playing junker Queen
to adopt a more aggressive playstyle in
addition many of junker Queen's moves
are most impactful at close range
including scattergun and Carnage
scattergun refers to junker Queen's
powerful shotgun last while Carnage is
the name given to her big sweeping ax
swing commanding shout sees jungko Queen
increase the health and movement speed
of herself and the teammates around her
similarly to Lucio Jungkook Queen's
ultimate ability Rampage allows the tank
to Lunge toward her opponents using her
magnetic Gauntlet once there she also
prevents her enemies from healing making
Rampage the first ability since Anna's
biotic grenade to apply an anti-heal
kiriko is the final new hero coming to
the game at launch and Is A Healer with
a DPS Edge called the protector of
kanizaka kiriko is a Japanese ninja who
trained alongside Hanzo and Genji under
the tutelage of her mother though she is
much younger and feistier than the pair
much of kiriko's abilities come from her
use of spiritual objects associated with
Shintoism such as ofuda and suzu and her
character as a whole represents the
merging of the spiritual world with
youthful intelligence as for her moveset
kiriko's primary ability is to heal she
does this by sending homing of Fuda
paper talismans offering the wielder
protection to her teammates her
secondary ability sees her precisely aim
and throw hakunai giving her an edge of
lethality that Rivals actual DPS
characters she also has the protection
suzu ability which sees her ring Isuzu
or Shinto Bell and cleanse an area of
debuffs and potentially devastating
attacks these attacks include sombra's
hack reinhardt's shatter ashes burn
Anna's sleep dot and junkrats rip Tire
Swift step allows kiriko to see her
allies through barriers in order to
teleport beside them making her the
first character in OverWatch who can
phase through walls her ultimate Kitsune
Rush summons a spirit Fox to guide her
teammates and provide them with
accelerated movement speed attack speed
and cooldown rates
[Music]
Kaplan previously confirmed that all
progress and cosmetics earned in the
first OverWatch will carry over to
OverWatch 2. according to Kaplan quote
we want to make sure that all OverWatch
Cosmetics come forward with you into
OverWatch 2 so all your progress matters
nothing is getting left behind no one is
getting left behind to ensure your skins
and progress carry over be sure to merge
your console accounts to a Battlenet
account
OverWatch 2 is also adding a new feature
called Mythic skins to the game
according to OverWatch 2 director Aaron
Keller these Skins are a tier above
legendary skins boasting Dynamic visual
effects and the ability for players to
customize their appearance
OverWatch 2 is not being designed in a
new engine but it is a greatly updated
version of the OverWatch engine
OverWatch 2 will have new Huds for all
heroes and perhaps most importantly
redesigns for all existing Heroes
sombra's changes will make her more
aggressive with her hacking ability
cooling down every three seconds hacking
will still briefly disable the abilities
of characters it afflicts but more
importantly it'll boost the damage they
take by 50 for 8 seconds the duration of
the hack her ultimate is also changing
so that it no longer affects Shields but
instead damages enemies caught within it
up to 40 percent of their Total Health
they'll also be hacked making them
susceptible to even more damage
bastion's changes totally rework the
robot removing its ability to
self-repair and its ultimate ability of
transforming into a tank bastion's
alternate fire provides an explosive
shell that's good for area denial and
its ultimate now transforms it into an
artillery cannon that can fire three
explosive shell files anywhere on the
map however its Sentry mode has been
considerably reworked Bastion can now
move while transformed turning the
character into a moving Gatling gun
while the ability also has a cooldown
now it's sure to be an essential tool
for Bastion players doomfist and orisa
have also undergone some changes with
orisa receiving three new abilities and
losing her character-defining protective
barrier making her more of a Frontline
fighter doomfist on the other hand is
being converted into a tank and has been
given a significantly more health and a
new defensive ability called power block
of Watch 2 enters Early Access on
October 4th 2022 this will consist
solely of the game's PVP mode with PVE
releasing in 2023 OverWatch 2 is coming
to all platforms that currently support
OverWatch including Nintendo switch as
well as PS5 and Xbox series X and S
[Music]